[Inaudible] what's up. Y'all what's what's what's
what's up. Y'all what up?
Oh, they are introducing core the books.
Sure. And the fantastic four in the MCU,
the hype is real. The hype is real Mariah.
The hype is real. Is the hype not real Mariah.
It's very real. I'm very excited. Right. But as.
Soon as I heard news, I was, I was upstairs laying in bed with my girl.
And, and I got in like.
Like the news dropped, I was looking at,
I was looking on Twitter and people were like, Christian bale is playing Gore.
The godwits are in the MCU. And I was like, what? And then, and then like,
there was, there were a whole bunch of other announcements where it was like,
they announced the fantastic four movie.
And John Watson is the one directing it. Right. John Watts, director Spiderman.
And I was like, so.
You're telling me, they announced Gore,
the God Busher and the fantastic four are going to be in the Marvel cinematic
universe. So-and-so and so look, here's here's here's here's the thing.
I only let me close the store.
I'm going to close this. I'm going, gonna tell y'all something. Let me tell you,
I was like, all right.
All your people out there who don't read comics y'all are not ready.
Y'all are not ready for, for the greatness that is going to,
that was going to befall the Marvel cinematic universe. So let's,
let's start with, go with the godwits,
but let's let's let's let's start with worthy God butcher, right? This dude,
this dude is an absolute monster, right?
So the God butcher was this guy who was on this world where it was like a
really, really harsh environment. And like his,
his tribe would pray to pray to the gods all the time.
And like the gods God's never answered, like he lost his wife and his child,
or like I said, it was a really crappy existence. Right?
It's like these two gods fell from the sky.
One of which was this guy named Noah who liked defeated the Celestials basically
at some point along the line,
but he had the sword called the all-black Negro sword.
So to the Godbold you're in being off at like the fact that the gods always
ignored them, decides to go on a crusade against the God. So he takes,
he takes the all-black Negro sword and then like recourses themselves,
Gore the God watcher. And then like just goes across the universe,
killing every God he can find. Right. So your wives on earth,
like a few thousand years ago, he fights the war for the first time beats,
his sled beats the hell out of Thor. I mean, just, I mean, just,
just not even in hell, would you see a massacre?
Like what happened when it goes to the God, which would be the hell out of food?
You know what I'm saying? Like it was, it was just, there was, it was,
it was just, it was, he was not prepared, man. That's that's all it was so,
so Gorgon know Thor gets, gets just readily crushed by Gore. Right.
And it's just, and then the gorgeous vanishes again.
So then they're like Thor in the present day ends up facing off against the Gore
and I think he loses.
And so what you went to finding out is that Gore had actually like in the
future,
Gore had like conscripted all these gods that he didn't kill to his cause in
order to create this God bomb,
because he was going to basically going to detonate this bomb at a time and kill
all the gods at once, right from the past, the present and the future.
So it takes four from the past four, from the present and four future, right?
Older King Thor who liked defeated Galactus.
It took like all of them working together to defeat Gore.
And then it all came down to modern day Thor who takes the all black Negro sword
and two mule nears. And then he overpowers Gore and then manages to be him.
Right. Go ahead. The wheel two hammers to be gourmet two hammers. Right?
Well that's, that's, that's, it's it's nuts, man. Like, dude,
here's the thing though. Gord, the guidebook,
which was like the coolest villain ever, right. You guys were going to chance.
There's a thing on my channel here on comments explaining it's basically Jason,
Aaron's a Thor, God of thunder. We cover the whole story arc with Gore. Right.
And it's like the coolest thing. It's just this amazing story. But like Gore is,
he's just such in such an amazing and awesome character. Well,
this is a guy who just crushed Thor like multiple times. Well,
I don't mean just like, Oh man, you know, like he got a couple of hits,
sounds like a high school fight, right? Where like, you know,
you got like one more hit than the other guys. So like you won. No, no, no.
This is like this, this, this, this, this, this was done.
Thor never had a chance, man. That's that's,
that's what that was like Thor never, never like in the first time they fought,
Thor never had a chance. Right? Like it was, it was just, it was.
And then we did, we got the fantastic four, right? Here's the thing.
If we get fantastic four, if we depend heavily for,
we need Jonathan Hickman's fan that we need, we need John [inaudible] son.
I want to say Jonathan.
He was fantastic for I'm tired of seeing like those terrible Fox fan have
planned for stick. I'm tired of seeing those stupid Fox. Fantastic four movies.
I want to see Jonathan. Hickman's fantastic. Four son, John inhibits.
Fantastic for here's why Jonathan Hickman's fan has like four, so cool. Right?
So Reed Richards has this son named Franklin and Franklin is like this reality
working kid. Right. And I'll, you'll see, I'll tell you, Matt,
let me tell you something. I'll tell you something in a minute, right?
How powerful his kid is right now. I'm sorry. I'm so excited people,
but it is a really it's it's an exciting time. Right? So,
so here's what happens. Right? So like Franklin Richards, when he was younger,
Reed Richards put these mental blocks in place. So we couldn't use his powers.
Why did we wish her to do that?
Because there was a story where Franklin Richards was watching,
he was playing with a Rubik's cube and then there was a TV in the background.
It was like, it was something like, why don't you grow up?
So Franklin Richard's used as like universal wide reality.
What bring powers to turn himself into Jesus and then like just sort of running
a muck. Right? So like once they got it back to normal,
he literally turned into, he looked like, Jesus, man. Well, he's,
he's all dressed in white with like this long hair. Like he looks like,
he looks, he looks like Jesus. Right? He looks like marbles. Jesus. So, so, um,
so Reed is like, okay, my kids too powerful.
We've got to keep this kind of under check under control. Right.
So I'm going to Jonathan, Hickman's fantastic. Four.
And like this grown guy appears out of nowhere, right? Like this,
this just grow.
This grown man just shows up in the Backstreet building out of nowhere and like
starts making his way towards the kids rooms. Right.
To Franklin Richard's room and Valeria Richards.
She's the daughter of Reed and Susan of Mr. And Mrs. Fantastic.
She's like super smart. She said the third smartest person in the world. But uh,
but he starts making his way towards the room and like the fact that other
forests are freaking out. Right? So like, man, what are we doing, man? Like,
what are we doing? You know,
there's this weird man who broke into our house and he's heading towards our
kids' rooms. Right. Well, you know, any responsible parent,
we go with guns and like, we would probably shoot him, you know,
because whatever. And so like, they go running towards lone towards this guy,
this guy looks at him and just like creates this foreseeable.
They can't get past. Right. Susan storm.
She was able to create force fields that could withstand the blast of Celestials
and she couldn't even get through it. Right.
It's like this guy was obviously not, not messing around.
So he grabs Franklin and then like, like he,
he like whispered something to him or something like that.
And then Franklin drops on the ground and passes out. Right.
And then he says something to the later yet and then leaves. Right.
So you get towards it, you get to like this,
this whole crazy story going on where like Reed Richards goes to this place
called the nexus.
We're just like all these alternate reality versions of like Mr. Fantastic.
Like one has the infinity.
I think three of them had the infinity gauntlets and then like,
there's someone on their powers are switched.
So like Reed Richards has the power of like the silver surfer or something like
that. Well, what they do is they solve the problem of everything, right?
Like that's, that's their whole goal. Like they just fixed problems.
So like there's a whole universe out there where all they do is grow food.
And then they just like take it to universities where food is, is not that,
not that prevalent. Right. It's like the coolest thing ever. Right. So, um,
so one of the reeds ends up going to this alternate reality where the Celestials
went crazy and basically forced everybody to worship them as gods.
And like when he came back to the nexus, the Celestials followed him back.
So it was like, Oh dude, this is kind of crazy, man, is this, this,
this is wild. So, so like the Celestials break into this whole place, right?
Just like this. Guy's like, dude, they follow me. And they're like, Oh my God,
we gotta, we gotta run. Right.
For like the infinity gauntlets don't work because the infinity gauntlets only
work in their own universes and they're not inside their own universes.
They're in like this kind of hub where like all the universities connect. Right.
You would think it works. It doesn't work.
So like these Celestials just come pouring in. Right.
And you start killing everybody.
So like Reed Richards from the main novel universe, it's like, dude, man,
we gotta get outta here. Right. So like he bales,
he goes and grabs some giant gun comes back and then like,
like they fight the Celestials off.
And like for the most part today saved and it's like, cool. All right,
this is awesome.
So then like what you end up finding out is the Celestials followed Reed
Richards to the main Marvel universe.
And so there's this point where like Reed Richards meets with Galactus. Right.
And galactose is like, do we need to talk about your son?
We need to talk about Franklin because its powers of woken up again. Right.
That's something that's like in the background, Franklin power,
Franklin Richard's powers, wake back up and Galactus has legitimately scared.
He's like, dude, your, your son's powers have woken back up man. And like,
it scares the hell out of me. So it was like,
[inaudible] go out to span. Glock is afraid of this guy. So it was like, okay,
like, like something's going to happen with Franklin. So,
so the mad Celestials followed read back,
well then like Valeria their daughter from the future shows up and tell Susan
storm, Hey, like things are gonna pop off. Uh, just so you know,
like these are gonna be really, really, really, really,
really dire when that happens, have hope that they will be safe. So you're like,
okay, cool. So, so anyways,
so the mad Celestials show up to earth with the intention of like killing Reed,
Richards and then like subjugating that whole universe and the,
and so like read someone's Galactus to earth and like the lack of spaces off
against Derek and like,
like his face faces off against all the Celestials and uh, and,
and then like in the being defeated, right?
The celestial is like merged into one big celestial unless,
so he ends up being defeated. And so it was just kinda like Dan sunrise,
like a lactose is basically dead. Like they kill him. Right. So it was like.
So like they started, they, they, you know,
like Reed Richards and Vincent's weapon called like Saul's anvil,
which is designed to like just shoot energy at Celestials and destroy them.
And like, they, like, it ends up,
like he fires it off once which breaks the Celestials back into the,
there are three parts again and then like, um, and then like,
like Wallace charging up the selections attack. Right.
So like Susan storm is sitting there like holding her force field up.
She's got her shield up and like the Celestials are just like hammered.
Like they're just, they're really hammering down a hell fire. I just like, boom,
boom. There's just, it's like the end harms. Right?
Like they're just hammering down on Susan's floor and she's just sitting there
holding as best she can. And then like the words of her daughter come up, right?
Like when, when things are at their darkest,
like have hope and that they will be safe and like up in the sky,
this light comes out of nowhere. And it's like, who, who in the hell is that?
And it's Franklin Richards and Valeria from the future.
And what you end up finding out is that Franklin Richard's from the future,
what to the past to woke is wake his powers up. Right. So,
so like he's the man that showed up in the pan task force building. And so,
so like he'd been teaching himself his younger self, how to use his abilities.
And it's like, son, like, like, so what he ends up doing is his,
his younger self just kept all his power. It didn't really use it all,
but he just kind of stored it all up.
He combined it with the power of his older self. Right.
So like adult Franklin Richards is the guy who's fighting. He goes to Goliath.
Like here's, here's the most,
it's the most amazing moment ever in the history of this moment ever in history
comics, like, like,
like literally Franklin like takes this ball of energy out of him and like
throws it in the galoshes and he's like wrong. And he's like, to me,
my Glock just like resurrects galactose from the dead and like makes him as
Harold. And it's like the most it's the most B ever. Right. So,
so like GoLive tennis was like fighting, do Celeste Jones.
And like Franklin Richards is fighting the celestial.
They managed to destroy him. Right. And it's just like, you know,
that's sort of, it's like, it's like the most beast thing ever. Right.
We need that in the MCU man,
like telling me that does not sound like it's, it's, it's amazing.
It's amazing. But anyway, uh, it's awesome news, right.
I'm probably never going to be able to sleep again now because I'm super
excited. I got myself so hyped up, but, uh,
this is it's it's it's it's going to be exciting.
It's going to be super exciting. So anyway guys, Oh, Warren,
bring this video to an end and uh.
Yeah man, I'll catch you guys later, please.